شارك مئات الالاف من النساء في مسيره في
العاصمه الامريكيه واشنطن وفي عدد من
المدن الاخرى في شتى انحاء الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ضد الرئيس دونالد ترامب
السبت بعد يوم من توليه مقاليد الحكم
احتجاجا على اجندته ولارسال رساله مفادها
حقوق المراه هي حقوق الانسان بحر وردي في
عاصمه الامه ضمن مسيره النساء في واشنطن
بدا الامر بدعوه للتحرك على وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي سيطرت على الاذهان خلال
الاسابيع التي تلت الانتخاب قد تكون مسيره
النساء في واشنطن الاكبر على الاطلاق في
تاريخ العاصمه الامريكيه ومئات الالاف من
الناس في شتى انحاء الدوله وحول العالم
يشاركون في مسيرات اخرى شقيقه المتظاهرون
سيمشي على الاقدام من موقع المظاهره الى
غرب الكابيتل هيل ثم الى حديقه البيت
الابيض ونصب واشنطن وبحلول الفجر كانت
الشوارع مليئه بالفعل بالنساء والرجال من
جميع الاعمار ومن جميع مناحي الحياه لديهم
مجموعه متنوعه من الاسباب للمشاركه في
المسيره قالت احدى المتظاهرات للدفاع عن
حقوق الرعايه الصحيه انا طبيبه ولا ارى
مستقبلا جيدا فيما قالت اخرى نؤمن بحقوق
المراه انا ام عامله لدي مسيرتي المهنيه
واود ان ارى اجورا متساويه للوظائف
المتساويه فيما قال اخر اعتقد اننا هنا
لنعبر عن مقاومتنا كان الدافع وراء هذه
المسيره للعديد من المشاركين فيها نهج
حمله ترامب الانتخابيه اذ قالت احدى
المتظاهرات لا اشعر بان ترامب يمثل افضل
ما لدى الامريكيين ولا اعتقد انه يمثلنا
انه بالتاكيد لا يمثلني فيما قال اخر
حقيقه انه يمثلنا في العالم الحر لا يعبر
عما تمثله الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وبالتاكيد ليس ما يعبر عنه النساء يتفق
المتظاهرون على شيء واحد وهو اقتباس
لهيلاري كلينتون من عام
1995 قالت فيه حقوق المراه هي حقوق
الانسان ودعت احدى المتظاهرات تعالوا
وشاركونا هنا اليوم